[Music]
well in the interest of public safety
we've repeatedly warned you about the
dangers of the creepy porn lawyer you
often see on television keep your kids
away from him obviously never look the
less this is a news show we want to be
fair so we have a standing invitation
for the creepy porn lawyer to appear on
this program whenever he desires we
contacted him repeatedly with this offer
and he says he will appear but only on
three conditions first we must stop
using our completely accurate creepy
porn lawyer nickname he doesn't like it
second we must issue a public apology
for calling him the creepy porn lawyer
and third he must appear alongside Rudy
Giuliani presumably so that he will have
a food source
we of course refused these conditions we
don't stand for conditions and we said
he could appear alone as he does on
every other cable channel or alongside
Alan Dershowitz who's publicly offered
to debate him his response and we're
quoting now I'm happy to come on your
show and debate Rudy Giuliani who
actually represents the president or any
other lawyer that actually represents
the president we repeated our offer the
creepy porn ler is welcome to come on a
show with a real audience whenever he
likes with the same conditions he gives
to other shows his response was this
quote Tucker is an ethical journalist
and a hack
well our feelings are not hurt that
invitation remains open the creepy porn
lawyer can join us anytime he has time
and he may have a lot of time coming up
we suspect